i don't need names but what are other
fellow publicly traded companies other
finance executives people on wall street
are they saying you're crazy are they oh
wait this is really interesting tell me
more about it trying to learn like what
was the reaction after the first 425
million dollars i think it was largely
ignored by every other publicly traded
company i i don't think there's a lot of
awareness or
to it when we did our due diligence
checks
we found overstock two or three years
ago had a few million dollars of bitcoin
on his balance sheet and that's it
right we couldn't find anybody else and
so this is off the beaten path but it
seemed like so rational to me like it
seems so obvious bitcoin is is digital
gold
it's basically engineered to be digital
gold what do you need in
a inflationary environment you need
something that's like gold but better
than gold
you have to make a choice
uh it was obvious that
the institutions were coming right i
mean you had uh
you had companies like fidelity getting
into this space
just you know six months earlier or
whatever but the fact that we're
institutional custodians was a big check
box grayscale was doing good business at
that time so
so
it struck me as being a rational thing
to do but no other public companies had
done it and it wasn't
it wasn't uh totally clear to me why
although at this point now it becomes
clear right in hindsight
so
we went through that we did the 425
million uh the stock traded up bitcoin
started trading up
at that point i started speaking in
public and you know you were the first
person i spoke to
i remember right
and and you know i learned most of what
i knew about bitcoin by by uh scouring
the internet and looking at your podcast
looking at reading all of the stuff that
was posted right and i tripped through
all these different things
and one thing i knew from your podcast
was
you always ask the question
right you know at the end right you're
like you can ask me a question remember
correct now you get to ask me the one
question so what i remembered about pomp
was he wants to know a book and he wants
uh and he wants
a question or he gives me a question so
i'm like gosh what question am i going
to ask pomp
and uh you know how do you learn bitcoin
you study twitter and you study youtube
and you surf the web so here's what i
know but
i know i get to ask you a question and i
know jack dorsey has bitcoin in his bio
so the question is how do we how do we
get jack dorsey to buy bitcoin next
correct right correct
and uh you know at that point
we're all alone is a publicly traded
company and people aren't quite sure if
we're crazy but what happens next is
some bullish things right i mean
i thought that um
when square bought bitcoin
that was a seminal event
right because one data point is a
question mark but when you had the
second data point you can draw a line
and so that was a big day
um when uh paypal
announced support for bitcoin
and they started uh sort of moving it
that was a big day that was a data point
right those were the data points
that moved us from 10 000 to 12 000 a
coin
and uh
at some point you know somebody some uh
citron research studied you know
discovered my stock and
andrew left i guess said something
positive
and uh the stock started trading up and
then it traded into the high 100s and
then it
it traded into the 200s and and bitcoin
started trading up and when we got into
the teens
people thought well there's something
interesting here
so the next step in our journey was like
in addition to me starting to
communicate why we had done what we done
the next step in the journey was to go
out and buy more bitcoin so we started
buying more bitcoin as part of the
treasury reserve strategy and that got
people's attention
then um
when the stock got to the 300 range
that was the highest it'd been in a
decade
300. so
we started thinking well maybe we can
raise more money and so we went back to
the convert market and we had
we were trying to raise 400 million
dollars in a convertible debt offering
but it was extremely popular
and we were oversubscribed so we upsized
the deal to
650 million dollars so that was a
screaming home run we we had uh we had
proposed a 32
to 37 premium we priced it at the 37.5
premium the high end of the spread
we proposed
like
1.25 to 0.75 interest we priced at the
low end of the uh of the interest rate
so we raised 650 million dollars at 75
basis points
with a strike price of 398. the stock
had not traded at 398 in a decade so it
seemed like a reasonable if you could
sell 650 million dollars of stock at 398
dollars a share seemed like a reasonable
thing to do with the time
so then we took that we bought bitcoin
with that so that was
we started out with um
with we're going to raise the money for
general corporate purposes and along the
way the discussion was what are you
going to do with it i said well you know
i want to be able to buy bitcoin with it
and they said well we should put that
you know into the disclosure i said yeah
we should disclose that
and then they said well are you sure
you're going to buy it i said yeah so
eventually it flipped and it became
we're doing it to buy the bitcoin so
that became
in the history of first right we're the
first public company to buy bitcoin on
the balance sheet where the first public
company the declarative treasury reserve
asset we became the first public company
to do a dutch auction which is in
essence like an equity issuance to buy
bitcoin right it's like i'm either
buying my equity back or i'm uh or or
issuing the equities so with the first
dutch auction
you know uh where the proceeds
eventually became bitcoin then the first
convertible bond to buy bitcoin
and uh i think that all of those things
rotated the shareholder base right
i think um
the most important thing was to be long
bitcoin right so in essence the first
publicly traded company where the
shareholder bases is long bitcoin
and it started out my aspiration was
it'd be great if half of our enterprise
value is based upon enterprise software
and half is based upon the assets
because before we did this
we got substantially no credit for the
assets
like people are basically taking the 500
million and they're like okay well
that's going to be worth zero
right or negative because you were one
times revenue plus uh just the cash in
the balance sheet yeah
yeah so
um if you've got a low growth cash cow
right that that's like being a dentist
where you're gonna make a lot of money
every year for a decade and maybe you'll
make five percent more each year for a
decade if you've got a low growth cash
cow but the money supply is debasing at
25 a year
it kills you right
it's like the road to serfdom is working
exponentially harder for a currency
getting exponentially weaker
what i saw was 2 000 people
doing a hundred thousand things right
every year
to make 50 million dollars
and then watching the enterprise lose
100 million dollars a year
due to a political decision so in
essence we're running as hard as we can
we're falling backwards and the
situation was literally hopeless right
like people
wonder where the bitcoin is hope come
from
well it just was hopeless right i mean
the operating business is hopeless and
and
you know okay you know you're going to
work yourself to death for a decade and
do a million things right with 2 000
people and you're going to be worse off
in a decade than you are today
that's operationally hopeless right
that's
and then on the balance sheet
if somebody says we're not even thinking
about thinking about raising interest
rates
it means for the next four years you're
going to get zero percent on your money
and is going to be worth
half as much
in 36 months as it is worth today the
balance sheet is hopeless